françois el bacha merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on l'a vu
finalement des libanais qui était en
colère aujourd'hui alors que le
président emmanuel macron est en visite
à beyrouth comment est ce que vous
comprenez cette colère ou soir tout
d'abord cette colère tout simplement ce
cd libanais qui sont fatigués fatigués
d'avoir la même classe politique comme
disait votre interview précédente
mais il faut aussi qu'on il faut aussi
que la population comprenne qu'on peut
pas plonger le pays dans le chaos ce et
qu'on a respecté certaines règles pour
le pont ne pas le faire tout simplement
le temps est grave il ya des impératifs
économiques
on est à trois mois seulement de
réserves monétaires et après les prix
des matières premières ne seront plus
subventionner qu'on a un risque réel non
plus seulement d'explosion comme ce
qu'on a vu dans le port de beyrouth mais
elle est le fondement totale de
l'économie
voilà alors ce matin le président
français s'est dit prêt à réorganiser
une conférence de soutien international
notamment avec les états unis alors dans
le contexte que vous venez nous décrire
contexte catastrophique est ce que c'est
une bonne idée selon vous oui parce
qu'il faut mettre la pression en fait
sur la classe politique pas dead
pas de réformes adèle tout simplement
c'est comme ça c'est par le portefeuille
en fait qui tient ces gens là emmanuel
macron de manque assez souvent là c'est
souvent répété un audit du système
financier déjà il faut ça il faut
comprendre en fait que les intérêts
politiques sont très impliqués aussi sur
les dans le domaine financier et que
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont entre
guillemets détourné d'importantes sommes
dans les dix dernières années ils ont
ainsi les banques par exemple ont reçu
65 milliards de dollars de profits et il
faut savoir que 43% des actions des
banques appartiennent à des personnes
exposées politiquement
donc voilà tout simplement comment la
dette publique s'est fortement accru ce
c'était des personnes au pouvoir qui
mettait le haut taux d'intérêt et qui
entre tour recevait les dividentes par
l'intermédiaire des actions qu'ils
possèdent et dans les banques
alors vous parlais à l'instant de cette
pression nécessaire assure les autorités
du pays pour avancer pour faire avancer
des réformes on le constate aussi un
diplomatiquement le chef de l'état
français est très volontaire face à la
situation au liban
comment est ce que c'est c'est perçu par
le peuple libanais cette stature du
président français la visite précédent
du président français a été très bien
reçu il ya effectivement beaucoup
d'espoir maintenant c'est un jeu de
poker entre les parties qui veulent pas
lâcher le morceau parce que c'est un
morceau qui les financent et la
population qui ne comprend pas en fin de
compte tous les tenants et aboutissants
de la chose
la situation est très tendue
il ya même certaines certaines personnes
qui menacent une guerre civile
donc on est un nid dans un sorte de
funambule
mais le liban le problème c'est que à
l'heure actuelle il ya certaines
personnes qui sont en train de courir et
non pas de marché sur ce fil de
funambule il faut à tout prix qu'on ne
fasse pas tomber ce pays jeudi dernier
emmanuel macron vous parler de guerre
civile vendredi dernier emmanuel macron
s'exprimait il disait si la france
n'intervient pas au liban
c'est la guerre civile assuré c'est ce
que vous nous dites aussi jusqu'à
présent je pensais plutôt à une
instabilité sociale et économique
surtout social avec hausse des prix
ainsi etc etc
mais les dernières déclarations
cela peut être une probabilité cette
probabilité augmente en fait et pourquoi
cette probabilité augmente justement
quels sont les acteurs en jeu qui
finalement m
finalement à mal la situation au liban
aujourd'hui c'est principalement des
facteurs internes en fin de compte
c'était une classe politique qui refuse
de lâcher le morceau
après il ya quelques quelques pressions
extérieures
on peut parler du de la lutte
d'influencé entre l'iran et les états
unis les sanctions qui ont été imposées
au liban la présence du hezbollah au
liban et son implication en syrie et
ainsi de suite
donc c'est un jeu qui est très complexe
au final alors les états unis justement
d'en parler tout à l'heure de cette
volonté du président français d'une
conférence en soutien au liban à paris
avec les états unis justement quel est
le but
écoutez déjà le président français est
celle de libaniser certains certaines
choses par exemple il a dit
textuellement au chef du bloc
parlementaire du hezbollah mohammad raad
qu'il fallait libaniser en fin de compte
le dossier du hezbollah et d'autre part
il a donné à ce moment là certaines
assurances dans le cadre du procès rafic
hariri comme quoi le verdict ne
concernerait pas le hezbollah
d'autre part et communique avec les
états unis il
il a dit à nos d'altran que les
sanctions américaines contre le
hezbollah en fin de compte ne faiblissez
pas le hezbollah
ce qui est vrai en fin de compte parce
que le hezbollah n'est pas tellement
liés au domaine bancaire c'est plus
c'est des alliés à des américains qui
sont en train d'être affaiblie par cela
donc on est dans un jeu où j'ai
l'impression plutôt que emmanuel macron
comprend réellement les et de manière
plus réaliste les enjeux locaux
s'il arrive maintenant à relever ce défi
responsabiliser comme ce qu'il dit la
classe politique libanaise là
et ensuite a provoqué par exemple des
élections législatives anticipées à
remettre une dose de confiance dans un
système on peut pas de quand même tout
jeter comme ça mais il faut par exemple
peut-être passer par une redéfinition du
système politique libanais le système
multi confessionnel c'est bien cela
tout à fait alors allez-y je vous en
prie emmanuel patron lors de sa dernière
visite a commencé à parler d'un nouveau
contrat précédemment la classe politique
évoquée à peine lire les réformes
économiques et monétaires et pas du tout
les réformes politiques et maintenant on
voit en fait que le président de
république hier a justement évoqué un
procès un procédé pour rendre le liban
comme étant un pays laïc on voit le
président de la chambre qui évoque aussi
la possibilité de voir le liban être
transformé en un pays laïc donc on voit
entre guillemets qui a quand même une
pression effectifs de la part d'
emmanuel macron pour arriver là alors
emmanuel macron qui demande du
changement on le répète il y en a eu un
hier juste avant sa venue c'est la
nomination de mustapha adib au poste de
premier ministre et pourtant les
libanais restent en colère on l'a vu
avec les manifestations de cet après
midi pourquoi ce nouveau premier
ministre ne fait pas l'unanimité au
liban d'abord il ya un défaut de
confiance dans le système et c'est un
défaut qu'on peut pas réparer du jour au
lendemain la classe politique elle a
perdu elle a perdu tout ce qu'ils disent
tout ce qu'elle pouvait avoir comme
quota de confiance auprès de la
population la population est fatiguée
deuxièmement il y avait toujours eu un
défaut le risque de représentativité des
instances officielles par rapport à la
population
et 3e point cette affaire a dit bête un
inconnu pour les libanais peut-être
qu'il est très connu en allemagne où il
a été ambassadeur peut-être qu'il est
très connu dans certains milieux mais
c'est un inconnu aussi donc c'est à
nouveau bien sûr c'est pas justement de
la nouveauté qui souhaitaient les
libanais c'est une autre nouveauté
qu'ils veulent le problème des
manifestants et delà de ce qu'on appelle
la révolution c'est qu'ils n'ont pas su
présenter des dirigeants
donc tant qu'on n'aura pas des personnes
aussi qui vont émerger de ce mouvement
on pourra pas avoir d'intérêt qu'auteur
on en aura pas d'épreuve de deux projets
alternatifs il faut absolument aussi
qu'ils commencent à présenter un projet
alternatif et sur des points convergents
la crise économique on a eu une le
projet maintenant politique pour
réformer les institutions et le liban en
étant et cetera et cetera
on a besoin à ce niveau là nous le
nouveau dirigeant c'est pas la classe
politique qui peut qui peut proposer ces
nouveaux dirigeants
c'est plutôt la rue qui peut proposer
ces nouveaux dirigeants pour redonner
confiance et dans l'urgence aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il y avait des solutions pour
apaiser les tensions
la promesse d'élections législatives
anticipées qui l'une des demandes de la
population
tout simplement alors on peut pas aller
si je vous en prie le pr les gens
demanderont qui voisinent président
quelques instants mais à alesi continuer
les gens demandent la démission du
gouvernement cela a été fait pour le
gouvernement précédent et demandent la
démission du parlement et demande la
démission du chef de l'état et ainsi de
suite
mais le liban a déjà été impactés
pendant de nombreuses années par des
vides dans ses différents dans ces
différents domaines donc ça résout pas
en fin de compte les crises ça nous
permet que le gagner du temps entre
guillemets pour la classe politique
finit par se marier sur la lassitude de
la population alors macro le président
emmanuel macron parallèle s'exprimait
donc hier lorsqu'il est descendu de son
avion et il est utilisé ces mots il veut
l'exigence sans ingérence est ce que
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
écoutez la france a beaucoup d'intérêt
au liban de par son histoire est aussi
maintenant le liban a une position
stratégique dans méditerranée orientale
et la france a des intérêts aussi
économique avec les consortiums
pétroliers
elle participe et total participe au
consortium qui va exploiter les zones là
économique
donc y'a de l'exigence par rapport à une
classe politique ça c'est sûr la france
a un rôle à jouer est là le problème
c'est que la classe politique à l'heure
actuelle le système marchait bien avec
les accords de taef parce qu'il y avait
l'occupation syrienne y avait un grand
parent il y avait un grand ordonnateur
et le puy que les syriens ont quitté le
liban
il n'y a plus de grands ordonnateurs il
n'y a plus de direction politique et ça
ça fait partie aussi des choses qu'il
faut réformer
on a besoin d'un exécutif tout
simplement et la france peut aider
justement à obtenir cet exécutif de par
son histoire et de par son influence au
liban
comment elle est ce qu'elle peut l'aider
très concrètement la france aujourd'hui
de mettre en place un nouvel exécutif ça
passe par quoi ça passe déjà peut-être
pas en ce moment la france menace
certains hommes politiques de sanctions
économiques
donc déjà il ya là il ya la carotte et
le bâton la carotte c'est l'aide à la
population
le breton sait les sanctions économiques
tout simplement
et le président français donc qui a
assuré qu'il allait revenir en décembre
cette perspective là est ce qu'elle peut
faire bouger les choses
c'est dans trois mois
c'est là à ce moment là que les réserves
monétaires seront ne seront plus pour ne
pourra plus les utiliser pour l'achat de
matières premières etc
c'est en fait le délai pour la mise en
place des réformes économiques c'est le
dernier moment où on pourra encore
procéder au sauvetage du liban et de sa
population
donc si des récits cette pression
fonctionne on a un espace pour le
changement et la communauté
internationale d'une part et la
population d'autre part qui manifestent
sont deux éléments pour aboutir à ces
changements
alors françois bachar battons toujours à
l'intervention du président français qui
doit s'exprimer d'une minute à l'autre
depuis beyrouth au terme donc de sa
visite en un mot françois el bacha
qu'est ce que vous attendez
comme des mots du président français qui
doit s'exprimer dans quelques instants
lors de sa dernière visite il a eu des
mots très forts adressés à la population
a dressé la jeunesse et il a aussi
déclaré son amour au liban et ça ça a
touché beaucoup de gens
maintenant il ya des paroles et des
actes il faut qu'ils qui se formulent à
peu près qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
réellement dans les mois à venir entre
la france et le liban
quels sont les moyens pour la france de
changer les choses voilà tout simplement
ce que je pense dsk tente enfin de
compte la population libanaise
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup françois el
bacha d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous n'arrêtez économistes
fondateur de l'île d'agneau